les olympiades c'est un peu l'opération
séduction de la filière ovine
on est parti modena temps les élèves des
différents lycées agricoles de la région
centre concours dans différents ateliers
ici on parle les onglons c'est un peu le
stand manucure des brebis
aujourd'hui je les note sur la
contention un petit peu faire entrer une
brebis et puis après donc l utilisation
de la cage de retournement est dû donc
du sécateur manuel on n'a pas mis de
sécateurs électriques bond par rapport
aux questions de sécurité 1
et puis après on note commence à se dire
ou le voilà les gestes et postures pour
pouvoir les noter par rapport à cela
faire attention hein pas couper trop
parce qu'après sinon on va arriver aux
100 et puis du coup la brebis ça lui
faire mal et pissaridès infectés donc
ces voix-là coupé mais pas trop à la
fois les compétiteurs sont tous deux
futurs éleveurs mais ils n'ont pas
encore choisi leur animal
loïc sait déjà ce qu'il veut faire je
vais faire du poly élevage en volaille
porcins et un petit allié ateliers aux
vins est avec vous il ya plombé thp
charge peut être me former dans la dans
les métiers de découpe animal pour
pouvoir faire de la production fermière
et vente directe sur faire l'élevage
revanche la tire pas forcément beaucoup
de monde donc quand on peut faire des
choses pour en attirer les trotteurs
[Musique]
toute la journée ils ont contrôlé les
puces électroniques vérifier l'état
sanitaire des brebis des agneaux trier
des animaux répondu à des quiz ce soir
il en restera deux les deux premiers ici
iront à paris le 23 février lors du
premier jour du salon de l'agriculture
pour la finale nationale des jeunes
bergers la filière ovine a besoin de
séduire au cours des dix prochaines
années il faudra trouver dix mille
éleveurs pour remplacer les anciens